hello John Perry here this is my well
first ever podcast II interview type
video uploaded to my channel it's fairly
long over an hour long but it's one that
you can listen to without having to
watch so while you're cooking or driving
or going for a jog or whatever and my
guest is a very interesting man ahran
raw he is the director of the phylogeny
Explorer project this is a website which
he hopes will be available to the public
sometime in the fall of 2018 and it acts
as a giant searchable evolutionary tree
on launch the tree will have over 50,000
organisms in it which you can explore by
clicking around and that number is just
going to increase as time goes on
they're gonna be constantly adding more
organisms to their tree and this is
going to be an absolutely incredible
tool really useful for anyone interested
in phylogeny interested in exploring
relationships at different plants and
animals and so on I am extremely excited
for this to come out in our conversation
we focus mostly on phylogeny and
cladistics and the history of taxonomy
taxonomy is humankind's ongoing attempt
to classify and categorize all living
things into a single comprehensive
system one of the most bizarre things
that we talk about is this strange case
of a single-celled organism that evolved
from a Tasmanian devil
it's now a cancerous parasite that
Tasmanian devils passed to one another
but it originally evolved from a
Tasmanian devil so by the normal rules
of phylogeny it should be classified as
a single-celled mammal because it
evolved from a mammal that's kind of
amusing shows some of the difficulties
in trying to come up with a single
system to classify all life on Earth so
without further ado here it is my casual
conversation with Oren raw Aaron is the
director of the phylogeny Explorer
project and we're going to talk about
that today and we're gonna talk about
just kind of the basics kind of an
introduction to phylogeny and how
phylogeny is different from the older
ways that we used to classify plants and
animals
and living things so aren't giddy let's
start right I guess a quick overview of
how things were in the past so before
Darwin Linnaeus to Owen okay well that
that's a good way to put that there's a
reason that Darwin had had already had
evidence to go on you know maybe people
would say that in Darwin's time that
there were no transitional species to be
found and he predicted actually that
there would be and he gave a number of
those predictions and and the two of the
most dramatic ones were were it revealed
one in 1974 that's the missing link that
he predicted there should be and that
was discovered in 1974 and also in
during his own lifetime immediately
after his book came out he suggested
that that there would be a bird found
with unfused winged fingers this would
be confirming his hypothesis that birds
had descended from from dinosaurs were
you know a dinosaur cousin reptile and
you know as I said that was vindicated
just a couple years later but with there
not being anything recognized as the
transitional species within his time
though there have been hundreds and
hundreds found since how did Darwin know
to make these predictions what was the
evidence that he had and the evidence
that he had was actually the taxonomic
tree of life that was Philo Janee
because a hundred years earlier in
pre-darwinian times a creationist
scientist named carolus linnaeus
originally a botanist was classifying
different types of plants and just
decided to classify all life and he
discovered that there were they were in
a nested tree pattern that you would
have different organisms within a parent
organism work if you'd have two
different sets of organisms within two
parent organisms and those those
preparing categories belongs to a larger
parent category that encompassed them
all and so on it went lots of different
groups within groups within all these
other groups and so it was a branching
Creek tree pattern and he had no way of
explaining that in Linnaeus time it was
considered that species were immutable
speciation had not yet been observed and
so the creationist prediction and you
know that you know of the way a good
hypothesis
suppose working you make predictions and
see if they're vindicated or falsified
and the creationist said that you know
that evolution would be proven when
there's a new species seen evolve but of
course we've now seen new species
evolved directly under direct
observation both in the lab and it
naturally conditioned actually
controlled conditions in the field so
many times then even creationists don't
deny this anymore
but of course they don't accept that
that's evolution like they used to
predict that it would be they said they
would change their minds if this ever
happened towards then it happened and
they never changed their minds yeah look
let's talk about what it was exactly
that Linnaeus is doing a little bit so
so he I guess in the past people had
been classifying animals more kind of on
what they did but Linnaeus wanted he was
trying to classify things on their
similarities and differences so he was
he was putting things into groups and
that's like if that's a good point we
can we can bring up too because I've
I've known people who did that that
classification by what they do you know
even the Bible does describe whales as
though they are fish right B whale makes
no distinction because if it swims it's
a fish and that goes not just for
vertebrates you know that that also
includes shellfish you know you know
they lived what is it the Bible
describes shellfish as fish that don't
have fins or some such thing you have
shells instead something like that and
the bible does describe things by what
they do for example in one area
bats are considered locusts they're the
four-legged locusts that the Bible talks
about because they swarm you know people
say well you know how can local be
considered you know four-legged the
Bible's wrong about that well it's not
that they're not talk about grasshoppers
they're talking about bats and then
elsewhere of course as everybody knows
bats are described as fowl meaning birds
because if it flies then it's a bird so
the Bible classified things by what they
do like I mean look at one of the
categories it's called creeping things
sorry if increase then it sits in the
category of creeping things and there's
there's a couple of named
classifications or categories that the
Bible puts down it's like they have the
beasts kind and they have the bird kind
what do we get something like a
Velociraptor and it's fully feathered
well is it a beast
or is it up heard and then our Bible
gets a little bit more ambiguous even
with the bird kind because it says there
are all sorts of birds and then every
kind of bird so there's there's kinds of
kinds so or or is it or is it sorts of
kinds because the Bible has no idea they
have no they didn't know anything about
classification so Linnaeus came along
and started classifying things by their
morphology by their physical
characteristics I would like to point
out it's probably I mean people in the
Bible we're doing they were just trying
to classify things by whatever they they
saw as being important right and people
are classifying animals for different
reasons they might be classify
classifying them based on what they
taste like right certain cultures might
be doing that whether or not they're
edible but Linnaeus was really focused
on morphology and that that's the big I
mean that's that is the precursor to
Darwin being figure all this stuff out
is because Linnaeus went ahead and
already did most of his job for him
right and in that's a really interesting
aspect of history you know like why was
why was Linnaeus so interested in this
I'm glad he was cuz it really revealed
you have to appreciate how much this
overturned Linnaeus world because as I
said he had no there was no concept of
evolution I mean so far as I know he
wasn't even aware of Lamarckian
evolution yeah I think Lamarck came
after Linnaeus and Linnaeus laid the
groundwork for you know what was
happening here but he didn't know what
was happening so he challenged the size
of a community to explain it and
specifically he challenged the
scientific community to explain why we
are apes because the best fighting
life-forms he realized that you know
either we are Apes or they are humans
and and he went both ways with this
because he wasn't sure so he classified
chimpanzees and orangutans both as a
subset of humans what the scientific
community did with that was you know of
course he said he would could fall under
the ban of all ecclesiastics if he were
to call it you know an ape a human or
human an ape and he was correct so the
scientific community at that time being
holy religious created an arbitrary
category called pongo which they put in
all of the known Apes other than people
all of all of them except us
which meant was bringing admission they
knew that that wasn't correct and so it
wasn't until about 30 years ago when we
complete the Human Genome Project and
there was a we got enough of the genetic
work done to realize that we actually
are Apes we're at the old arbitrary
construct of Pongo was invalid
so they've restructured it so now Pongo
consists only of orangutans and fossil
relatives like Siva Pittacus
Gigantopithecus Rama physicans and so on
and then we have the Hohmann na which is
the chimpanzees the gorillas bonobos and
humans and then a handful of other
things that would be discovered in the
fossil record later because it turns out
there was a whole bunch of fossil
species that we no longer have that's
one of the things that I like about the
project that we're working on we're
focusing as much as possible to make
sure we get all the fossil species in
that are known because there are way
more fossil species then there are
current ones I want to talk about your
project in a minute but let's let's nail
this down real quick here the kind of
the differences between phylogeny and
what Linnaeus was doing so Linnaeus is
he's the guy that kind of invented this
binomial name system so we are Homo
sapiens
actually we're Homo sapiens sapiens but
we he came up with that name he came up
with the idea of species genus family
order class violin Kingdom domain I just
had to look at those because I don't
have them memorized but so he came up
with this this like you were saying in
this nested hierarchies and he wasn't
really looking he didn't understand he
didn't he wasn't thinking evolutionarily
so he he wasn't thinking of these things
as actually being relatives you know we
have this system of family but he that
was an analogy in his mind right he
didn't actually think that these
different species were literally related
that didn't really come until Darwin's
time but you know so so we have Linnaeus
coming up with this and a lot of people
started getting on board you have
Linnaeus wasn't really doing much with
fossils was he no there was those almost
no fossils known in his time his benefit
wasn't even known what
fossils were the first few fossils had
been discovered but they did their
significance wasn't realized as a matter
of fact it would be with some people
that were saying at the time that
fossils were the creations of God and
not to test our faith but literally just
to [ __ ] with us and so at the point when
they first discovered these they didn't
realize that they were living castes or
castes of living things or once living
things so they literally thought that
these were just that artistic things
that God has made or that prior cultures
perhaps have made interesting so so
[ __ ] air was he's a French guy and he
was doing I'm saying his name wrong
because he's French
Cuvier he he was the big fossil guy he
did not accept evolution either ideas of
evolution where were being tossed about
during his day but he wasn't really all
that interested in him but what he did
notice is that there were certain eras
there were creations before the modern
creation is how he saw it so there was
there was different worlds if you dig
down deeper in the fossil record
yeah then we have Richard Owen and he he
was grouping things again the same way
that Linnaeus was and he had this idea
of archetypes so he saw all these nested
hierarchies that Linnaeus had found and
he saw those as archetypes so God had
somehow had some kind of a basic plan
for mammals and he would tweak it
slightly and build different things and
so he came up with this name dinosaur
which meant terrible lizard when he
found well when the first dinosaurs were
brought to him I don't I don't believe
he actually dug him up himself but he's
the one who came up with that name and
first classify them Owen famously took
credit for other people's discoveries
yeah he was a very controversial figure
he was very well respected in his day
but eventually his practices caught up
to him so that like at the end of a very
illustrious career he started getting a
lot of bad press and one of the odd
things that he had was it was his idea
of God as a tinkerer that God could
learn from his mistakes
so the God would be able to make these
prior creations like dinosaurs but they
wouldn't be as good as the things he
made after that because why would God
make dinosaurs to be bigger and better
and not just bigger but you know they're
more advanced I mean they would better
respiration more energetic why would why
would God make animals like this and
then make mammals not as good so he
didn't he couldn't see it that way he
had to see mammals as being improvements
over dinosaurs and the dinosaurs were
just cold-blooded sluggish creatures
like like the reptiles we have now like
like like lizards or crocodiles or
something like that he had to envision
it that way because he imagined that God
would create these things learn from the
his prior creation and improve upon his
own work with in the next edition or the
next series and so he thought that
rather than one species changing into
another he thought that you would end up
with a line of animals that would wear
out and and become smaller and slower
and everything is so God would have to
come up with a new series so I have a
lot of sympathy for Ono so here he is
the guy that said let's build an amazing
Natural History Museum and let's make
this if you've been to the National
History Museum in London it's the thing
that everybody else copies it's the
Smithsonian is like a cheap knockoff of
what Richard Owen built and full cred
that thing is amazing yeah he wanted to
be it's not just the exhibits in it it's
the building itself is is a marvel at
all of them you've been yeah yeah just
just the stonework inside you know where
they were they like that well they'll
hide small sculptures of monkeys or
birds or whatever and to the end of the
stones themselves it's it's really
magnificent both inside and outside it's
an incredible edifice
yeah and that was his baby I mean he he
wanted to he was doing this first for
spiritual reasons he wanted to worship
God with a museum to his to God's
creation and actually naturalism which
is its that the tradition that Darwin
was brought up and that was a that was
really a thing that was started by a lot
of clergy that had free time because
they only work one day a week
essentially would start going out and
documenting rock formations and animals
and there
there's a there's a strong link between
religion and the early days of
naturalism and that's why if you go back
and read stuff especially before
Darwin's time all the naturalist
literature talks about God a lot in it
which is really weird for us today
because obviously it's scientific
literature doesn't usually mention God
anymore where science and now a multi
cultural practice so we we keep
different religious and cultural ideas
out of it but good for people to realize
- I mean like American creationists have
no idea that you know virtually everyone
who who - who determined the age of the
earth who determined the geologic column
who who evaluate all these fossils and
their significance and and the
geostrategy all of this these were all
believers these were all Bible believing
Christians right they just they didn't
buy into the current Dogma which is a
new thing where you're supposed to deny
all the scientific evidence instead they
mean they they figured that you know why
would God create something to contradict
his word I mean if it wasn't like they
worship a book and they deny a reality
they they weren't denying either one
whereas modern Christians I'm sorry to
say I've met several who will state
outright that the Bible is the only
source of truth in our world and let
everything else be a lie and that seems
to be the modern philosophy but those
sorts of people did not exist in the
early days of these scientific pioneers
yeah that that's kind of an American
invention I actually it might it might
just be an American invention because if
you go to England and you talk to people
in the Church of England people like
pastors and stuff there still is a
strong Naturalist tradition going on in
the Church of England there's still are
preachers that will go out and spend
most of their time studying rock
formations and that they're still doing
this and they're still writing papers
it's really the yeah the seventh-day
Adventist Ellen White she was a
prophetess for the seventh-day
Adventists and she had all these visions
of the flood and that kind of
kick-started the modern young earth
creationist movement here in the United
States which has now been shipped back
over to England so now they're they're
dealing with out there
- about thing that they were facing is
as Linnaeus had discovered that there
actually is a tree of life know
something that creationists want to deny
they want to say that there's no
geologic column
even though Christians of the day
verified there's a geologic column we
can prove it exists and we can't explain
it and then on top of that Linnaeus also
a creationist thought you know a
Christian also determined that there's
this tree of life and it's a real thing
they can all verify they can prove that
it exists but and by that I mean that
this this analogous you know this
grouping that appears when you draw it
out on paper it looks like a tree so
it's a practice branching tree pattern
to the organization of life that is
actually real and so they're creationist
Christian Bible believing Christians who
are saying that these things are
verifiably true and we can't explain it
and so Darwin then discovered that
species could be whole new species could
be evolved and he discovered these with
these finches what he thought were
different species of birds and he
brought all these birds back home and
then an ornithologist studying them says
no they're all finches and they're all
evidently related to each other the
earth these are different species of
finches these do not interbreed they're
distinctly different species and they
all come from a common ancestor and this
is of course what evolution is but to
realize that new species could evolve
this way explained everything it
explains use each geostrategy and it
explained the tree of life both of them
unified at the same time so when Darwin
had this new revelation he turns to
carolus linnaeus esta manera and
suddenly it all made sense this was the
explanation that they had been looking
for for a hundred years yeah yeah and
that brings us to phylogeny so back in
the day
Owen and Linnaeus they were just
grouping things with a sort of idea of
an archetype and now we have Darwin who
comes along and realizes whoa these
things are actually related to each
other that's why it looks exactly like
they're related to each other so tell us
how things have shifted in taxonomy
taxonomy just being the art of
classifying things I suppose there are
some people that say that the word and
taxonomy should not be used
where I don't have a problem with using
the word a taxonomy but we're changing
from a Linnaean construct to a cladistic
construct and the difference is that
Linnaeus had no way to to account for
evolution because it wasn't a thing in
his time right however the modern system
is it has to account for evolution it is
in fact you know to a large degree based
on it so what you have is you originally
try to classify beings by their by their
physical physical traits and such but
you don't always have an explanation for
these like for example I've mentioned a
couple of times before that ooh
anteaters aardvarks and pangolins all
three had lost their teeth and so it was
decided that these must have you all had
a common ancestor that lost their teeth
and then these three lines diverged from
that but then we got their genome back
and it didn't realize that nowhere where
usually you get the genetic confirmation
that all of these classifications are
correct there are occasionally
Corrections as well and this is one of
them where it turned out that that the
Anteaters are in their own little group
meals in our threat that they should
stay there but then pangolins were more
closely related to kriya danse and
carnivores and that aardvarks are
actually more related to elephants so
what had happened was that they're
different ancestors lost their teeth yet
differently on different times different
occasions different lineages and then
all ended up eating ants because there's
nothing else they could eat now that
they were toothless that kind of thing
or maybe they had started eating ants
and no longer needed their teeth so they
were able to continue to survive without
that whichever way that goes but so in
phylogeny then is different than the
Linnaean taxonomy because it has the
morphological characteristics going one
way and then it's twin nested because
then it you can then go for Corrections
or confirmations using the genome as a
ways of checking yourself so now we have
a way this works exactly like on the
Maury Povich sure we know when they do
the thing about you know doing the
genetic tests to see who your father is
we can actually do that now it's not
analogous it is actually the exact same
principle
so that when you you can take your DNA
and you can compare that to the genetic
records that we have for people all over
the world because there's unique
mutations that occur in all these
different people all over the place and
we can map those those unique mutations
or those unique ARVs or what have you
there's a whole bunch of different
genetic distinctions that show how
humans have migrated across the planet
and so we can verify your ancestry using
these genes so it's not just within your
family it's not just to determine you
know which which guy is your father we
can go much further than that and of
course we can go much further than that
they've used the genome to map that all
dogs for example we've got hundreds of
different different breeds recognized by
the American Kennel Club but all of
these are derived from four different
genetic lineages that come out of
Asiatic wolves so all the domestic dog
breeds we have were we're down to four
different times that people had
collected wolves and began breeding
domestic dogs from these wolves and of
course eventually interbreeding them
right I had heard about the the idea
that wolves domesticated themselves they
could eat our garbage suggested to me
yeah and sort of domesticated us or
created this this what is it liaison or
an alliance with us yeah it's really
neat to imagine being kind of the first
humans are like yeah I'm gonna take this
wolf that sometimes eats our kids and
yeah hang out with it so let's talk
about the phylogeny Explorer project
which is I don't know you didn't start
it right you you picked it up no this
was something that I've been wanting to
do mm-hmm for like always
yeah okay so when I was a kid I was
never creationist um my family was
Mormon and they had this they actually
observed the tradition of not trying to
teach their religion to their children
until they turn eight years old which
they can't early to be the age of reason
but by that time a science teacher in
2nd grade had given me a science book
with it that had a cladogram about
dinosaurs
so and it shows how all these different
things were related and of course that
just made sense to me and so that was
just before you know my mom finally
my age birthdays okay well here's the
Bible it's the absolute turn to my
immediate reaction is no it isn't
because look what it says here so that
the said I'd already been immunized
against believing in the mythology but
I'd always been fascinated with the
classification of life I always thought
it was it's there's value in knowing
where you are in things I don't
understand how people can and I know
lots of people like this cannot tell you
what states or countries border where
they live yeah I just don't understand
where they are on a map well if you were
going to continue walking to the door
that what would you eventually see
what's the next state or country north
or west of you I know people who don't
know that likewise people who don't know
where they are in history who don't know
where that you know like where
televisions invented before or after
automobiles things like that if you
can't answer these questions you don't
have a perspective on where you are
chronologically likewise I want to know
where I am in the Tree of Life and it's
it's bewildering to me that other people
can can look at this but so simple to
put together it's like you know the
Sesame Street game you know one of these
things is not like the other right right
you see a dog in a cow right one of them
is different right we'll say a cat a dog
and a chicken and a cow
well now suddenly the chicken is the odd
one out what they know that the cow
doesn't really belong with the cat and a
dog right it's it's that easy to put
this together in many occasions and so
what I'm doing with the phylogeny
Explorer project is there was a prior
attempt to do this we want to create a
navigable online encyclopedia of the
entire taxonomic tree of life so that
people they know I wanted to use be used
as a tool for scientists I have some
scientists reviewing what we've made so
far and I'll be talking to them in the
next couple of weeks about how to
improve it to make it a tool that they
will use at it so that it has value for
them and then once we do that then it'll
be have value as you know for teachers
and students but people will be able to
navigate through and see how everything
is interconnected now there was a prior
valiant attempt to do this was called
the the Arizona Tree of Life project
which was completed like in two
and I think was it was mm that was
that's when they'd lost their funding
and that was essentially what had
happened was it hired a bunch of PhDs to
build a webpage which of course was cost
prohibitive there was no need that did
all these people didn't have to have
doctoral degrees just to create a
webpage right like you can create the
webpage and then have it be
peer-reviewed and then you don't have to
pay for all of that construct and that's
what we're doing we're we're going
through the peer-reviewed material where
we're accessing that the established
works the fossil works org for example
where it is calm fossil works
nonetheless you know has a chronicle of
all these different fossil finds and
they've already got a classified and
then we look up wherever there are
discrepancies or things that are not
listed there we we go to peer-reviewed
research materials and find where
exactly things are supposed to be
according to that the latest studies and
then we put in the citations that the
anymore infobox ideally and we're going
to be turning this over to the
scientific community to fill in all of
that you know though all the more info
in the citations and such and we're just
building the tool and fleshing it out
and we've been working on this for more
than three years now we've got a couple
of different database engineers create
the database the spine of it the first
attempt collapsed it looked nice but it
collapsed as soon as we started putting
heavy data into it the second one is
able to withstand all the data and it
has to be correctable to because at some
point we can come in and say no this
this needs to be changed over here we
need to be able to move this node and
all of its daughters simultaneously over
here we have to be able to do that and
so there has to be corrections that we
can make as well that's been built in
and we've started filling in the the
species and so far we're right around
50,000 species Wow but somewhere forty
so forty to fifty thousand species have
been entered into the system so far and
that's through volunteers that adding
that it not many volunteers either but
over three years time and so we've
already fleshed out our database much
more so than the original Arizona tree
of life project had done because they
didn't have anywhere near this many
species and
and they didn't have they didn't have
the as many fossil species either they
were whole huge taxonomic groupings that
weren't even included because they were
all extinct or when heavier they weren't
relevant to what they were talking about
that that the purpose of the goal of
this is not the species themselves
because there's a lot of cladograms will
show you you know but beautiful
depictions of white variants of species
we're talking about the importance of
the different clades and my video series
the systematic classification of life
explains you know what does it mean to
be a mammal what does it mean to be a
monitoring what does it mean to be a
nephrons owen or a deuterostome all
these serving clade names they have
significance there's a reason that we
belong there yeah so so tell everybody
what a clade is I mean most of my
audience should know that but some
people want your audience probably does
know that yes but a clade is a taxonomic
grouping that includes all of its
descendants so like it when the
creationists are always arguing for one
kind you know giving birth to a
completely different kind and that would
violate the laws of evolution and the
clades are one of those laws it's the
law of monophyly that you could never
evolve out of your ancestry so that once
you are a mammal for example then it
doesn't matter if you eventually if
someone is born with no memories or no
hair you know any of the other
descriptive characteristics for what a
mammal is we don't say that that person
is not a mammal anymore because it's
based on your phylogeny so if you were
if you were a human child you have human
parents and you don't have you know ten
fingers or two arms or two legs or you
or the you know the size brain that
humans are generally described as having
we don't say you're not a human anymore
you are still a human even if you are
different right so you can be as
different as you want to be and even if
you eventually become a a sustained
clade that your parents were not you
still belong to all of your own
ancestral clades that they did so you've
just added a new node to that that maybe
your parents didn't belong to right and
when I say parents of course I'm drawing
two final line because evolution is not
individuals out of
a single family attractions of course a
population level thing that's like the
evolution of languages there was not
like there was never a first guy to
speak French who then had to get
wandering around Latin speakers do you
know looking for somebody to speak
French with that's a good analogy so
okay so it's just just to give people a
little bit deeper understanding of
clades let's talk about all the
different clades that humans blonko not
all of them but what are the main clades
that humans belong to you
well you know how Linnaeus had those
seven categories in my series I show
that the seven was a mild
underestimation right right yes I used
them as signposts so that we will still
make reference to the family of
hominoidea for example that you know
that the family of apes that we belong
to and that great apes are the subfamily
and we'll make reference to you what is
it the class of mammals I forget because
they're not they're not really important
in the cladistic concept yeah and this
is something is a little bit confusing
and I actually see people screw this up
in scientific papers sometimes is that
where we're actually at a point in
classifying animals where we mix the old
version with the new version and there's
confusion pretty frequently about that I
don't know how the scientific field can
get past that but there is a mixing of
the old and new that's confusing and
what people try to cling to that old
Linnaean construct you know when you
have an infra Order you know we ran in
for class you're just you're just trying
to wedge too much stuff in there and
then and that construct was never was
never gonna be capable of doing this so
we have we talked about five named
clades because there's a lot of clades
that are not named you know they'll
throw in a cladogram that we can tell
that you know these organisms I have
these different synapomorphies in common
and so that they should be found an
apparent clade if it's it's not the same
parent clade as this other one which has
which only has another parent clade
below that and so the name of the clade
isn't important so very often draw the
cladogram without any names on it and in
fact when there's quite a few
in our cladogram that we have to
literally make up names for just for the
system to be able to the system can't
create something unnamed unless we name
it unnamed okay so will will will either
put in that the clade is unnamed or will
put in you know deuterostome three okay
something like that
as I said well Cajun aliy we will
mention you know mammal or the you know
rarely the phylum our kingdom or
anything but when we get into the family
and genus there's some practical
application there that people can cannot
be so easily lost so let's dance the
back in time through humans so we've got
you know we're Homo sapiens sapiens so
we that's that's our species and then
beyond that where did that the clades go
as we expand back back for their time
well well again you know Linnaeus had
had seven and then when when I first
went to college they would already
realized that that was incorrect that
they had to add a eight one four domains
but in my systematic classification of
life series I just uploaded the twenty
sixth episode and I still have at least
a dozen more to go and most of my
episodes cover more than one clade at a
time so the one of them I think I cover
a half a dozen clades all in one episode
so I mean that would be like Linnaeus's
entire construct in the first two
episodes yeah we have something like
forty ultimately in the whole series so
where we start from I mean the it all
begins with eukaryotes a lot of people
would want to argue that you know since
bacteria we're here first we must have
evolved from bacteria but we didn't
evolve because evolution is is a aid
ancestor descendant relationship so it's
it's a merrily defined as descent with
inherent genetic modification and that
doesn't really apply when we're talking
about horizontal gene transfer when
we're talking about microbes very often
too often we're talking about horizontal
gene transfer because bacteria and some
other mark herbs can just they can
exchange genetic material on contact by
number of different meats and so that
creates a very muddy phylogenetic tree
so that when we are doing a
the easiest way to do this is that when
you get into multicellular organisms now
you have an ancestor descendant
relationship that is more easily defined
and then the horizontal gene transfer
can influence that but it doesn't it
doesn't create any new branches where it
where it would in the other was we say
that The Tree of Life Rises out of a web
like a mesh network Darwin
his first sketch was this little tree
like structure and he said I think this
is how things were and he was absolutely
correct for multicellular organisms but
when we get down to microbes a lot of
evolution happens and a much stranger
way you really have to go down to the
gene level to actually see evolution
happening because that's a cellular
level these things are just swapping
genes with each other willy-nilly and so
you don't really have an evolutionary
tree in bacteria you have this this kind
of grid the web you have it you have
evolution happening I mean there is
mutations occurring within genetic
lineages and their ancestors are
affected by these in the in technique
that would be evolution but it's muddied
by the fact that there's also outside
influences confusing that yeah yeah each
each gene is evolving through descent
with modification but they're being
passed and swapped between different
cells so you have so you're part of the
confusion with with the abiogenesis for
example with the emergence of the first
eukaryotic cells now we're number the
first living cells is that the cells we
have today have organelles that have
been maybe not created by evolution they
could have been created by and
endosymbiotic relationships with
bacteria or by exchanging different
genetic components or weird constructs
that not everything has in common 9 when
we look at the complexity of the cell we
think that this is absolutely uniform
for all living cells at all of the same
machinery exists doing the same things
the same way in every other cell but but
that's not the case
there are other organisms for which the
genetic construct and the mechanics are
are surprisingly different
maybe the same most basic components but
they're structured differently or they
behave differently where the mechanism
is awry somehow and they're still
functional they're just functional in a
different way all implies an
evolutionary ancestry or at least I in
the evolution mixed with the horizontal
gene transfer at no point do we get the
intelligent designer thing ever makes
sense
in any of our analyses so you're saying
if you go back if you have humans you go
way far back in time you find eukaryotes
so there's this there's this clade
called eukaryotes right and what does
that mean okay so a eukaryote is a
larger cell Danna ProCare the
prokaryotes are bacteria and archaea
which archaea are not bacteria they're
so - called archaea bacteria but they're
actually different and they're more
closely related genetically to us than
bacteria is so it wouldn't be fair to
say that we evolved from bacteria
because it's not it's not exclusively
evolution it's not a an ancestor
descended relationship too much
horizontal gene transfer so what once it
becomes exclusively a relationship we
and ancestor descendant relationship so
we can definitely call this evolution by
that point it is in a eukaryote cell and
the eukaryote cells have the organelles
which sometimes aren't necessarily
eukaryote cell organelles but they may
be endosymbiotic enslavement of another
bacteria like mitochondria if everything
except excavates the most basic forms of
eukaryotic life has mitochondria in it
some excavates do some don't so the the
idea is that in these earliest organisms
one of them was infected by a Rickettsia
bacteria that was itself disabled
somehow the Rickettsia didn't have the
ability once it got into the cell began
to affect it - its thing and it was
supposed to it was supposed to vacate it
lost its escape mechanism and became
found in the cell and so that that the
might of the mitochondria replicates you
know more or less symbiotically with the
with the cell not necessarily always and
it has its own genome in the genome was
not human the genome that the
mitochondria has his bacterial and then
plants did the same thing so they
started out as eukaryote so they already
have the
Andreea but then they also got
cyanobacteria the reason that they can
photosynthesize is not because they got
that ability at all is because they
enslaved the cyanobacteria to do it so
then moving on from from eukaryotes a
half a dozen clades up if through a
little complexity there we get into
animal which has a slightly different
stuff cell structures and plants we
don't have the hard cell membrane and
then i realized i'm going back to like
middle school for most yeah well what
well let's rewind here could because
here's here's we're kind of that i think
that the newest thing for a lot of
people comes in because i didn't learn
about clades when i was in high school
and so i assume that a lot of people
haven't either so in the eukaryote clade
we humans are eukaryotes but so our
fungus they are also eukaryotes so are
plants they are eukaryotes so when you
go way back to the base these these
really basic clades pretty much
everybody is included and as you move
upwards towards modern humans the clades
get smaller and smaller and smaller so
we start with eukaryotes and then you're
saying we're moving up to animals so now
with animals we're excluding plants for
including fungus we're excluding
single-celled organisms one of the
things people don't realize is there's
no such thing as a single-celled animal
animals are by definition mississauga
except for an exception that we'll talk
about later with cancers so but yes okay
so people want to say that you know i
ain't no damned animal but if you know
what an animal is an animal is any
multicellular eukaryotes that has an
internal tie justic tract and every one
of them does and so there's one that has
a slit in it that people want to argue
that maybe that's not but any of that
because they have actually folds to make
the attract internal so yeah even leave
even though it's a slit and you could be
if you had hands small enough you could
peel a part that still has an internal
digestive tract so that the definition
holds and so people this is the
definition of what an animal is and it
applies to everything and so with every
category with every one of these clades
you can say okay well i'm an effort owen
you know what is an effort zone and
effort zone there's an animal that has a
through gut / a mouth at one end of the
anus at the other you know that that
internal digestive tract is connect
both ends instead of just one because
there's a lot where there's a lot of
organisms like jellyfish for example
where the mouth and the anus are the
same thing yeah
how lovely a thought is that and then
then there's others like deuterostome is
a fun one for me because it's it's where
you wear the in in the development of
these cell for the animal cell it's you
have a the just the digestive tract
opens from one end and goes to the other
now in most animals it opens from the
mouth first and opens all the way
through to the anus but in deuterostomes
which sadly includes us the door-stones
is a clade right it's okay and so
they're our development as deuterostomes
begins anus first and then it finally
erupts on the other end into the mouth
so there was there's literally a point
and this is the first thing that
develops so you have this little
blastopore and the first opening begins
it's not even a dis just've tract yet
the very first thing it is there's
literally a point where all you are is
just an [ __ ] yeah it makes sense
right mike is my favorite biological
joke we're just fighting against our
nature all the time okay so so you've
got eukaryotes then Deuter star then
animals then deuterostomes
so we're getting more and more specific
we're getting more and more towards
humans getting bits of course you know
because there's that what if you move
between yeah let's say let's talk about
like two or three more and then then I
believe looks that we can we can get
into vertebrates tree well actually
vertebrates is quite well was just good
gift of vertices if underpriced is
really good to talk about because
vertebrates the first vertebrates of
course for fish and so if we're talking
about the clade the vertebrate clade
we're talking about all fish we're
talking about all reptiles all on
pipiens
all mammals well don't we got to talk
about fish for a moment because people
are gonna say exactly that you can't
evolve out of your ancestry then how is
it that we're not fish anymore but the
but there's a there two words that no
longer have a taxonomic meaning where
they had to change the taxonomic meaning
one of them is
there's no there's no hard and fast
definition for fish because first of all
it's not just vertebrates and there's
some argument over this but the only
earliest the earliest fish
we're chordates even before they were
vertebrates you know and again we have
to argue about what is exactly a fish
and then if it's gonna be that fish are
cold-blooded because almost universally
they're considered to be cold-blooded
but now we have warm blooded facially
we've just recently discovered right and
then we have there a fish that are that
are universally accepted as fish
everybody understands these are fish but
they walk around on four legs
and I'm not even talking about you know
tetrapods I'm not an angler fish that I
drag around on four legs so there's an
there's fish I think that even don't
even have gills so there's a what the
hell is a fish of you fish is a
colloquial idea so either it is that
there's no such thing as a fish because
we don't have a definition that's hard
and fast and consistent or we're all
fish and there's another one reptile
this word had to change too because
people want to imagine that at some
point in our ancestry we were a reptile
by this colloquial definition we're
reptiles a cold blooded scaly thing with
claws but there are reptiles that are
again universally accepted as reptiles
that don't have scales that don't have
claws you know that don't meet all these
criteria so there had to be something
else so now that reptiles have been
redefined so they're died absence or sir
opsins but you know generally we say die
absence so die absence include the
reptiles and our ancestors were never
died absence so our ancestors like
Dimetrodon were synapsids
and they might have looked like reptiles
in the eyes of somebody like Richard
Owen but we don't see them as reptiles
now just because they're cold-blooded
scaly and claws doesn't mean they're
reptiles
likewise amphibians we were never
amphibians either because amphibians is
another clade that branched off after
that and led to frogs and salamanders
and so forth we have things that we
would classify as infamously it works
like kind of like the word carnivore
because there are there are sharks are
obviously carnivorous but they're not
carnivores because Carna
or is a clade that is exclusive only to
one subset of mammals when you say that
there is no such thing as a fish or no
such thing as a reptile anymore what
what you're saying is that in cladistics
which is now the dominant classification
system in cladistics we don't have a
fish clade we don't have a a reptile
clade because the clade needs to include
all of those organisms plus all of their
descendants and because because mammals
mammals if you go back far enough in
time we evolved from fish so if you were
to have a fish clade mammals would be in
it yeah so they used to have this
classification that I mentioned before
where you know Apes were in the genus
Pongo and humans are this different
genus so we couldn't have evolved from
apes but then when it was realizing this
was only like 30 years ago that our
ancestors you know the Australopithecus
we actually do come from apes well then
the same thing goes that when you go to
next step further because it was
popularly I popularly envisioned that
all of the old world monkeys were in
this sister group called
cercopithecoidea but then they
discovered prophetic idea you know Egypt
of Pittacus and proconsul and things
like this that did that you know they'll
qualify as old world monkeys no one's
going to argue this so now the word
monkey applies the same way that the
word eight dozen people get really weird
about being called monkeys but the thing
is is if you define all primates by
other their classification that they did
traits that all primates must have in
order to be classified as primates you
describe people and when you describe
these subsets characteristics of the
appli runts the dry nose primates while
we are drying up dry nose primates and
we get to the next one which is the Emma
forms or anthropoid eeeh either word for
that clade means essentially monkeys
because that's all it is it's old-world
monkeys and it's new world monkeys and
how could you have old-world monkeys and
new world monkeys and have a common
ancestor that wasn't a monkey itself
obviously if we're going to be
monophyletic then that our ancestor
ended up being a monkey and there are
some paleo primatologists who now agree
with this and say we're top of the
leading once knew you know Fleagle and
Nelson they were saying
way back in the day that yeah our
ancestors were definitely monkey so we
actually did come from monkeys and
truthfully really are still monkeys
right now because there's no
classification for it for the you know
the people will point to the size of the
ribs or for the shapes of the teeth
there's no consistency for all of them
that distinguishes them from us if you
describe all the characteristics that
identify what a monkey is if you have
all of the ones that all monkeys share
in common you describe people and then
if you go to the old world monkeys and
do those krepp those characteristics you
describe people again and then if you go
to the next subset for hominoidea which
is the family of apes you're describing
people again and then the subset great
apes you describe all their
characteristics you describe us again
and one of the characteristics for
example for Apes and for great apes at
least is a dramatic reduction in the
number of hair follicles so that
chimpanzees and gorillas have the same
number of hair follicles as we do and
there's a general reduction in the fur
and there's a reduction in other things
too so that when people say well they're
hairy and we're not we're just as hairy
as they are believe it or not the big
change that has happened from owen to
Darwin or well I guess it was have
started happening after Darwin that this
move to cladistics where we start naming
and classifying things by their
evolutionary history Owen had this idea
of archetypes and so a fish kind of
makes sense within his his system
because there is kind of an archetype
you know a general thing that's fishy
like and that's that has its own
usefulness and it actually still has its
own usefulness today kind of you know in
layman's terms right I think we
mentioned in a prior conversation when
you go to a restaurant to order fish
yeah you know you're not expecting that
that you know beef or pork argument or
chicken are going to be on those menu
items even though they're all
technically fish in realistic sense we
have a colloquial understanding and that
colloquial understanding would not
include a whole lot of others when we
order fish we're expecting only that
we're gonna get one subset of teleosts
we're not gonna get lung fish we're not
gonna get shark right and this is why
there is so much confusion between
like when when you have a layperson
talking to a cladistic person sometimes
people can talk over each other there's
confusion because we have we're actually
using the same words and a lot of cases
but we're using them in different ways
which for me I I care a lot about
language is actually kind of frustrating
I wish that we would invent new words
for all the stuff now that we have a new
classification system but I'm not the it
is for some people to realize that we
are not we were never reptiles but we
are we are just really weird monkey fish
right so you know we've outlined the
main difference between the old
classification systems and the modern
classification systems we've talked
about what a clade is we've talked about
some of the confusions that come up I
want to talk about the the big the
really weird thing in cladistics
in that we now have examples of
single-celled mammals and single-celled
yeah single-celled marsupials there is
this cancer that formed in Tasmanian
devils and if you get cancer one of your
cells has evolved it's rebelled against
your body essentially it's its genes
have changed and it's trying to survive
and reproduce inside your body as if
it's its own organism now and it will
start to reproduce and it and it's it's
babies will take over and you know
usually a cancer kills its host by just
being a really crappy citizen right so
it'd be like it's it's like a human
colony that will all the animals birth
is a good example of that right right if
we continue to consume the way that we
are I mean we are essentially a cancer
right now on our ecosystems but so so
you've got a you've got a cell that
rebels it starts evolving and it's your
immune system is trying to attack it it
Willy
its ancestors will evolve ways to avoid
the immune system there's this battle
that goes on and if you lose you die and
your cancer usually dies with you but
this cancer in a Tasmanian devil we
don't know exactly when it happened but
it's somehow evolved the ability to
spread to other Tasmanian devils so
when a Tasmanian devil bites another
Tasmanian devil usually in the face
this tumor will transfer from one devil
to another and it actually does that
through a fairly sophisticated mechanism
where it tricks the immune system and is
saying that no I'm part of you it don't
attack me and at first we thought that
maybe this was only possible because
Tasmanian devils are so genetically
identical to one another but we've
actually found now that know this this
tumor actually has developed a mechanism
to shut off the immune system of its new
host and so we have what is essentially
a single-celled organism that evolved
from a mammal and so according to
cladistics this is a single-celled
mammal how should we deal with this I'm
glad that that's well know it kind of is
up to me to say if I'm going to be
working on this project I'm gonna be I'm
just going to turn that over to the
scientific community to work out that
one this is one of the there's actually
many examples of where Nature doesn't
fit into our our simplistic or our Wiens
of you know look at look at the laws of
nature that we come up with you know
people want to say that these are laws
that are decreed by a god but really
this is just a human trying to summarize
in the simplest terms possible what we
can confirm to be true and if you don't
phrase it correctly or if you don't work
out your formula right you know that law
could actually be wrong you know it's
like Newton's law of gravity was
actually wrong yeah there's there's not
going to be a there's not going to be an
absolute consistency probably because it
this wasn't an intelligent design
clearly evolution is such a messy
process that no matter what
classification system we come up with
there's gonna be weird exceptions
there's gonna be just things that drive
us crazy and this is straw Denari weird
exception yes yeah yeah it is but the
fact that we found one we've actually
found some a similar thing happening in
dogs they have an STD that's actually a
cancer I mean a cool cancer and then
there's one in hamsters there's one in
clams and there's actually been a few
cases in humans but in humans has always
been you you need your Mew
to be you need to have like HIV or
something that's messing up your immune
system to get these cancers so it's we
actually don't know how many
single-celled organisms out there
actually evolved from multi-celled
organisms there could be more than then
we're currently suspecting but one of
the things that I that I want to point
out about the new cladistic approach to
classifying organisms that's it's
different
well we do have these issues these
problems that come up but the thing it's
so beautiful about it is that there
actually are right answers and wrong
answers when we're trying to figure out
what evolved from what and that means
that this is a system that scientists
will be able to perfect and modify for
you know years to come until it's nearly
perfect and that's not something that
we've had before in our classification
systems we haven't been able to actually
say oh this is right and this is wrong
but we can do that now yeah what it used
to be is to something like the way we
would classify vegetables it's any plant
that we eat that's not a fruit and
that's that's not a useful means of
classifying anything and as you said
there's no way of confirming it but now
that we have the genome we can actually
back up whether we are correct or or
where we need to make a change right
right
so not a perfect system but it is
objectively verifiable which gives it
value so let's just can I have you right
now explain to the audience what the
what people will be able to do on the
website kind of what it's going to look
like once it's up okay lead the video
series that I'm doing right now the
systematic classification of life does
show they have screenshots of the
website as it looks now or the database
as it looks now and this is there's no
illustrations that you can see it's just
a bunch of may be confusing lettin Latin
words if you're you know if you're not
already fluent in this in the study so
it's easy for people to get lost in it
and that's why I made the video series
is kind of new yet again signposts too
Gide people long this is what you're
looking for this is the next thing to
click on that sort of thing so that
other people will be able to navigate it
as as we improve it there's a ways of
prettying this up and and we're on the
Phase two of that right now one of our
admins came up with an idea for how we
can make this look a little bit more
attractive to other people who are not
scientists but it were an interest in
this subject and then every clade has a
more info box and ideally every clade
will have illustrations or encyclopedic
depictions and citations and so forth
included in that
of course when we're talking about tens
of thousands already entered and heading
to a goal of millions most of those
boxes are going to remain empty for
quite some time but you know many of
them are going to have some degree of
information in there right to start with
and so it what we're hoping to do when
we unveil this in in fall of 2018 was
what we're shooting for we we actually
meant to do this two years ago and then
that's here and then but yeah and so now
the dates been pushed back to the fall
of this year September October or
something like that it always takes
longer than it does yeah so when people
can finally access it we want to make
sure that that that we have the the
server capacity for for people to use
this on a large scale or to at least
review it on a large scale it's going to
be it's gonna be not as pretty as some
other cladograms that you can access
right now I mean there's one like called
one zoom I think that this is just
lovely to look at but it doesn't teach
you anything there's no there's no
academic value to it and that's that
that's really what we're looking for
there are I think three or four other
cladograms that are that's pretty and
they are yeah they don't have they don't
they don't have the practical
application that this one does so our
purpose in this is to have a
peer-reviewed tool that the scientific
community is actually using right and
updating and updating and they're
eventually that we're just going to pass
it over just hand it over to to control
it but we want to make sure that it sits
in a secure safe position so that
nobody's going to screw it up
now we've paid an awful lot for the the
the securities that have been built into
it for example and then that that makes
it a little bit it's difficult to enter
data into it because of the the strength
of the securities that are already there
you know with with demons
Martin marching around the system every
two minutes or so and keeping the backup
copy of everything and then keeping
things on separate servers and all of us
so that when you get that the website to
look at it you're you're not even
looking at the actual thing that's
somewhere else and that's backed up
somewhere else yeah yeah you know so we
could there had to be some little bit
they had to build off an awful lot of
the substrate that had to be worked out
before we could start entering any
species at all so I'm impressed that
we've we've done as much volume as we
have already and there is some value of
just in looking up the names if you know
what the names mean and there's a search
feature so that you can go directly to
if you know the Latin name or ideally if
you know the colloquial name for any
particular animal I mean you'll be able
to find that somebody somebody
challenged me the other day they asked
for two things a spider monkey and a and
a raven and I was embarrassed to see
that when I looked up neither one of
those things were there so these two
things are not there yeah that's a week
we had a meeting about that well I I am
really really excited for this product
to go live we'll have to have a party on
my channel when you when you finally
make it light kid just to be able to go
through and explore that
I'll probably get addicted to that for a
while I'm really impressed with your
work you being able to pull this
together and you know work with such a
diverse group and get researchers
involved so that everything can be fact
checked and you know peer reviewed this
is amazing
just putting it together for that for
that reason alone it's been crazy
because there in every video that I do
in this series I'll have to go and look
at the screenshots that I'm gonna look
at I have to look at them and verify
that these things are where there's
pose to be because they haven't always
been and I'll find discrepancies that
you know you you'd expect even if you're
working with professional scientists but
you and let's be realistic I'm working
with volunteers and I'm surprised that
the volunteers have actually done as
well as professional scientists have on
most instances that's been remaindered
but there's some things that have
exposed even errors on the scientists
behalf and Sol sauce oh I found a couple
places where the scientist has screwed
up and not always accidentally there's
there's legitimate debate in science as
to as to what animals go where I got one
for you there was a scientist who fudged
the figures for religious reasons he
wanted to believe in a designer and he
couldn't Aneesa this guy's a well
respected authority but he wanted to
believe that there was an intelligent
designer and he didn't like the fact
that some of these things were
classified in in clades that no longer
exists and so he insisted on classifying
them in claims that do exist so that
they all seemed to be intended and so he
urged it was inexcusable and he was the
only person to have done any research on
this particular organism so I had to
notify a whole bunch of other people say
hey can we need to look at this and
somebody somebody do the peer review on
this because he's done the only study on
this limited not well known thing and
everything he said about it is
fraudulent oh yeah
he fixed I maybe I shouldn't talk about
the details of this I'm not gonna talk
about the details of this but there I've
seen the same thing happen for
conservation reasons because there are
laws about you know which species have
protected in which or not and I've
actually seen people fudge data to to
fit that which is a I agree with them in
one way and that it's important to keep
these animals conserved but I do not
agree with them screwing up with the
data to make that happen but there are
ideological reasons that people screw
with the data and when there's so much
so many organisms and this this stuff
was happening at such a fast rate then a
lot of times things don't get
double-checked even in you know
peer-reviewed journals it's not deeply
peer-reviewed so I'm I'm sure that
there's going to be Corrections and
things that continue to happen
which is it great that you guys have
figured out a way to make it easy to
correct things in your system so I'm
really excited about this just so
everybody knows there are links in the
video description that are going to show
you our ins videos that he's already
done on phylogeny and when the
phylogenetic explorer project is open to
the public when the website is actually
live and you can actually go explore the
Tree of Life for yourselves I will have
a link to that in the video description
as well well thank you just remember
this this is going to be a work in
progress that will never be complete
yeah it's too many too many organisms
and they're changing exactly exactly
it'll be over when the internet fails to
exist
like that I saw a commercial where the
guy said he's finished reading the
Internet the internet gives you a little
things you've given up into every
website he saw some crazy stuff okay
well thank you Aaron
great having this conversation this was
actually our second time doing this the
first time my recording failed and it's
funny because at the beginning of that
you said you're trying a new recording
program and I said do you have a backup
yep that was unprofessional with me so
this time we're using YouTube's tools
and hopefully that's solid so alright it
was a pleasure and of course I offered
to be on your show because I respect
your channel now well thank you though
yeah be great to do something again in
the future especially once you have this
project up and running some of you have
probably noticed that Aaron is he he
talks a lot about creationism he is in
where how do you locate it here in Texas
I'm in Texas yes I am a Southwest
Regional Director of American Atheists
yeah so so the creationist stuff pings
you all the time it's it's constantly a
topic and so it was pleasure I look
forward to talking to you again in the
future when their projects up and
running so long thank you much